après 10 ans d'excavation de toutes
sortes de dizaines de milliers d'heures
à le tailler et l polir le diamant voit
enfin le jour ici à la casse d'urville
serti dans l'écrin de l'ancien édifice
du royaume sied prête à briller de tous
ses feux et éblouir le monde
le hall d'entrée est sombre et lumineux
à la fois le studio beaulieu lepage est
une réplique du studio de création de la
caserne d'ex machina la salle de
spectacle peut être configuré pour
recevoir autant du théâtre du cirque que
de la lutte
là on va la voir en boîte noire cédant
configuration 100 sièges parce que
justement pour le parcours inaugural les
gens participent à une activité de
cirque
robert lepage souhaitait pouvoir
présenter plus souvent des créations de
sa compagnie ex machina à québec mais
sans se confiner dans une seule
discipline artistique
ces propos rien que ce n'est pas le
théâtre diamant c'est le diamant le
diamant n'est pas un théâtre est un lieu
multidisciplinaire pluridisciplinaire
ouvert à toutes les formes d'art
les lieux permettent d'accueillir des
décors d'envergure et tous les
équipements sont mécaniques à travers sa
modernité
le diamant est un hommage aux traces du
passé un savon alliage entre les époques
on a aussi conservé des éléments tels
que nous les avons retrouvés quand on eu
le mandat d'architecturé par exemple les
arches de bois sont telles qu elles qui
ont juste été un petit peu
réparer on a aussi on voit ici les
colonnes de fonte qui ont été trouvés
pendant les travaux
lors de l'excavation donc on a dû les
intégrer pendant les travaux on a aussi
par exemple dans l'heure d'entrer en bol
et grande vitrine daury style art déco
qu'on avait trouvé dans le cinéma de
paris le projet au coût de 57 millions a
pris 15 ans pour se réaliser cette fin
de semaine plus de 3000 curieux
visiteront les installations
la programmation débute le 7 septembre
avec la pièce les sept branches de la
rivière ôta ici tanya beaumont radio
canada québec